Trash versus garbage, is there a difference?
Well, my grandmother taught me that trash means plastic, leaves, metal, tires, wood, etc....
...and garbage means food waste, I guess what we might now call compost.
This linguistic distinction wasn't something I'd ever learned in school.
I mean, to me, this is a trash can and this is a garbage can.
But the Oxford English Dictionary records "trash" as originally meaning broken...
...or torn pieces of wood, twigs, splinters, cuttings from a hedge, straw, etc.,...
...while "garbage" originally meant giblets of a fowl or entrails and waste parts of an animal.
So grandma was right!
These days, however, many of us in the US use the words "garbage" and "trash" interchangeably.
And if you live in the British Isles, well, "rubbish."